Jordan Bardella est candidat pour les élections
européennes. Mais quel est son programme ?
On vote le neuf/06
prochain et il est temps de voir ce que les candidats
proposent. Avant de commencer,
je préfère
préciser qu'il s'agit d'une synthétisation de son
programme. Si vous souhaitez en savoir plus,
rendez-vous sur leur site internet
de campagne pour avoir davantage d'informations.
Jordan Bardella,
tête de liste pour le Rassemblement National,
parti pour lequel il est président.
1 programme en 3 points 1ère point, l'Europe qui protège.
Pour le RN, l'Europe est 1 passoire,
c'est-à-dire qu'elle
permet à des personnes venant d'un autre pays
de s'installer
et vivre donc dans 1 pays de l'Union européenne
et cela entraînerait donc beaucoup plus d'insécurité.
Face à ça, il propose d'instaurer 1 double frontière
européenne et française.
Pour compléter, il faut être expulsé,
c'est donc les clandestins,
les islamistes et les délinquants étrangers.
En faisant de fond texte,
1 agence de lutte contre l'immigration clandestine.
Le fond texte,
c'est l'agence de l'Union européenne qui vient
contrôler donc les frontières
extérieures de l'espace shegen.
Le RN vient également donc critiquer la concurrence
déloyale. Présentation de l'Union européenne.
Face à cette critique,
le RN propose donc de mettre en place 1 véritable
taxe carbone aux frontières européennes,
notamment sur les matières premières.
Alors, petite pression,
il faut savoir que cette taxe carbone,
elle existe déjà et a été intégré au pacte vert
depuis le 1ère octobre deux-mille-vingt-trois.
Et lors de ce vote à la Commission européenne,
le RN avait voté contre
Elle a pour objectif
d'atteindre la neutralité carbone d'ici
deux-mille-cinquante
et de venir taxer les matières
comme l'acier ou encore l'électricité.
2e point du programme,
l'Europe qui
produit le RN s'oppose donc contre le pacte vert
qui a pour objectif
de réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de serre.
Leurène va donc proposer différentes mesures.
Il souhaite proposer 1 loi mangeant
français tiroir
pour objectif donc de soutenir les agriculteurs
français, d'investir dans la technologie
comme le nucléaire ou hydrogène
et s'opposer donc dans des énergies renouvelables
telles que les éoliennes.
En terme d'écologie,
leurène va proposer toute 1 série de mesures
afin de se tourner vers 1 écologie raisonnable
qui se tradurait par exemple
avec l'assouplissement sur les obligations
européennes de rénovation énergétique des bâtiments.
E R. N.
Vient ici pointé du doigt
les règles qui sont instaurées donc aux propriétaires
sur euh
leurs appartements,
notamment en location,
qui sont de véritables passoires énergétiques
et le renne souhaiterait donc
retirer cette réglementation
pour soulager les propriétaires.
3e point du programme,
l'Europe qui se respecte.
Alors le renne vient ici critiquer 1 robe
trop bureocratique
et si reprocher toute la complexité donc des processus
décisionnels au sein de l'Union européenne.
Il y aurait donc trop de réglementations
et des processus beaucoup trop lent.
Alors qu'est-ce que la bureaucratie ?
Il est important de noter
il y a plus de 27 pays qui font partie donc de l'Union
européenne et donc le processus décisionnel implique
forcément donc
des moments de négociation.
De discussion et d'échange, et par conséquence ça prend
effectivement du temps.
Ce fonctionnement a quand-même certains avantages,
par exemple de veiller à la
protection des droits fondamentaux,
donc des citoyens de l'Union européenne,
ou encore de favoriser la coopération
entre les États-Unis.
elle soulève des débats sur l'équilibre des poules,
voir entre l'Union européenne et ses États-Unis.
Je vous dis à très vite sur le décritage
donc d'un nouveau candidat.